welcome everybody um i've been
mentioning that
this segment has to be done and the
reason this segment has to be done is
there are some real problems
for the democratic party to solve in the
next two years and certainly beyond that
because joe biden
won uh but he barely won in a sense
whether joe biden ends up with 290 or
306
in the end in the electoral college the
reality is that he will have won
by a couple hundred thousand votes in
three
to four states and it's fantastic news
that joe biden won and as i said
during the live stream on saturday
during president-elect biden's speech
that this is something to celebrate this
is something to rejoice about and yet at
the same time as of right now and the
votes are still being counted
more than 71 million people voted for
donald trump
71 million people saw the last four
years
knew they had an alternative and said
give me another four years of donald
trump
millions of people who didn't vote for
trump in 2016
said even though i didn't vote for him
after four years of insanity
i now am going to go out and vote for
donald trump
that's a disaster early 2020 exit polls
also suggest joe biden did much worse
with hispanic voters in some key states
than hillary clinton did in 2016.
in some cases by significant margins
we're still waiting on
final data you have this massive
recession
impossibly bad unimaginably bad handling
of coronavirus some of the worst in the
world
and democrats can maybe tie in the
senate we have to see what happens with
the georgia runoffs
barely win the presidency and lose seats
in the house of representatives
now there are two sides to this and we
have to be able to hold both sides there
will be people who look at me
talking about this and will say david
but trumpists are idiots listen
there's two sides okay on the one side
there are many trumpets that are
ignorant
there are many trumpets that have been
bamboozled and weaponized into oblivion
there's no question that a huge part of
this is unempathetic people
uh ignorant people hyper partisan people
uh super religious people who have
fallen for trump's supposed religiosity
even though biden's actually the
religious candidate
but we can't only focus on them because
there's also a lot of problems on this
on the left and within the democratic
party
if the starting point is let's find dumb
people and point and laugh
and just attack trumpists as dumb uh
okay i mean listen that can be a
starting point and there's plenty of
them
but if the goal is how can we avoid what
was almost
another disaster and how can we actually
get policy successes in the future
we have to look at what's happening on
the left as well there's no way around
it it would be irresponsible not to
and in fact we have to take some
responsibility because
understand that this election almost was
democrats lose some of their advantage
in the house
don't get the senate and trump gets
re-elected instead
we have democrats lose some seats in the
house
win the white house with an unclear
senate as of right now
and razor thin margins in a ton of races
it's pathetic to lose house seats
not win the senate and barely win the
white house when this president has done
everything wrong
and the united states has become a
complete and total laughingstock
around the world it's a disaster and the
first thing that we have to understand
is something i've been saying for years
which is that donald trump didn't create
the people we now call trumpists
they've been around for a long time
they've mostly defaulted to the
republican party
they've been brainwashed by right-wing
media they've been lied to by the
republican party talk radio
has been right-wing for decades and has
been preaching to them
racism and xenophobia and anti-science
anti-intellectualism it's all been
around for decades
what donald trump did was provide an
avenue for them
to be more comfortable expressing their
views in public
and has coalesced them but step one is
trump didn't create these people and
they don't go away when donald trump
leaves
secondly we have to recognize that the
71 million people that voted for donald
trump
aren't all racist or xenophobic or
anti-science or religious nuts
many of them are one of those things a
bunch of them are all of those things
but there are also tons of people
tens of millions of people who vote
republican as a result of culture they
grew of the culture they grew up in
uh because that's what their family does
because they don't really pay that much
attention to politics but they just kind
of default to we don't vote for
democrats
uh sometimes it's because of actual
false beliefs about democrats but
71 million people is a huge number and
there's
no one thing that applies to all of them
other than
the democratic party has to do something
about at least some of them if the
democratic party wants a shot
in the future and in total there is a
huge
cult-like element to the american right
as was posted to our subreddit
there is no what i would call retail
strategy to deprogram people at that
scale when you're talking about 71
million people
particularly because the deprogramming
that would need to be done is different
for a lot of these different groups it's
not all the same for 71 million people
so there should be some wholesale
strategy now
some of you will email me and say david
these people are deplorable like hillary
said why are you defending trumpists
wrong question i am not defending
trumpists
i care about winning by winning winning
winning
by moving the country to the left
lifting the standard of living
lifting the quality of healthcare and
education having a country that isn't
laughed at
all over the world it's just a
mathematical reality
we need some of these people to have a
shot at real progress
okay we can't just skate by with razor
thin margins
while the other side also has record
numbers of votes
so while it's fun for now you know
there's this brief period
where i get it right like we laugh we
say you guys lost they're so
triggered it's funny we got biden they
can't even admit it your dear leader
leader trump is going bye-bye i i get it
like i'm part
i think it's it's cathartic and i think
it's it's
uh satisfying to some degree
at some point the democratic party has
to account for
why they continue to barely be able to
win
despite the right putting up cartoonish
lunatics as leaders and candidates
now there are systemic issues to solve
as well so you've got the trumpets on
one hand
you've got the problems of the
democratic party gerrymandering and the
fact that republicans live more rurally
and democrats live more in urban areas
that's a structural disadvantage to the
left i've talked about it before
the senate is fundamentally undemocratic
california has almost 40 million people
they get two senators
wyoming has 550 000 people they get two
senators that's a structural
disadvantage i think during impeachment
we we calculated something like the
senators representing
17 percent of the population had enough
votes in the senate to acquit trump
yes the electoral college is a
structural disadvantage
a republican president has only won the
popular vote once
in the last um i think it's the last 20
years right i mean
bush lost the popular vote in 2000 but
got elected
bush won the popular vote in 2004. i
think that's the one republican that's
actually
won the popular vote for president in
the last 20 years
now lots of people see the whole thing i
just laid out
and they claim to have the solution and
this is actually a virus that's going
around not the pan not the coronavirus
but the virus of thinking that you have
a simple answer
because it works well in a tweet or
whatever like it's really popular now on
twitter to say
stupid democrats think they need to move
to the center but really they need to
move to the left if they move
left they win you'll see tweets like
every democrat who ran on medicare for
all one
just go way way left and every democrat
wins democrats take over
there is huge self-selection bias there
the democrats who ran on medicare for
all
were mostly in districts where they
would win regardless of their position
on health care because of the dynamics
of the district
other democrats say we need to start
winning morality messaging
and show that our policies are really
the moral majority policies well
that matters to some voters in some
places the point is
anyone who's coming to you on twitter
reddit youtube
cnn with a simple answer this is the one
thing
they are trying to simplify something
that is really complicated i have no
interest in doing that and i'm not even
pretending to have the answers today
i'm laying out the stakes and the
conversation so
you know if you want to have fun and
make fun of dumb trumpets there's no
shortage of that
and it's satisfying and it's
entertaining and
we participate in it to some degree but
it's not going to help us win let's not
imagine that it will help us win
10 and 20 years from now making fun of
the trumpists won't give us the returns
on policy that we want
that's how i'm thinking about it i want
to hear from you
and hear your ideas and we're going to
continue talking about this during the
transition phase